It's my absolute pleasure to work on both and some room and Nadine Kreisberg two
talks at Google.
Gordian is a French or tour composer in Chamonix Trans researcher.
She has been 15 years learning and practicing,
one going in shamanic trends and collaborating with researchers in neuroscience
and psychiatry.
Aside from this research coding also collaborate extensively with artists and
these workshops exploring the influence of trends on creativity.
She has written several books,
translated into many languages.
The one that was translated to English is June in [inaudible] footsteps and we
still have a few copies here.
No Dean's work is about accompany people on their journey to understand who they
are and becoming it.
She combines video stores from depth psychology and Dreamwork to business
coaching and leadership training from trauma relief,
Emdr to intergenerational work.
She works in both one on one and group settings in the bay area and around the
world.
I had the pleasure to work with both coding and Nadine personally and I know you
weren't in for a treat.
Please welcome Corrine and Nadine.
Hmm,
thank you Mario.
Thank you for having us today or super excited and thank you for calling
everyone out there.
And everyone here,
I think you are in for a treat because,
um,
we're going to tell you about an amazing story,
which is the encounter of ancient technology and the newest technology.
Uh,
these days we keep talking about technology is technology,
technology and we forget a lot of the ancient technology which we still carry
in,
which we can still tap into.
Um,
so we're going to tell you a story at the cutting edge of neuroscience and
psychiatry and psychology,
but rooted in ancient schools of wisdom and what's called shamanism.
Um,
I'll give you the main headlines and then we'll go into it.
So,
uh,
you've all heard or experienced or heard about or experienced trance,
a different state of consciousness where we can access information and transform
things.
And usually when we think about trends,
we either think about shamanic traditions where there's a drum and someone goes
and talks to the spirits or we think since the sixties about taking LSD or
mushrooms or Iowasca and so on and so forth.
So all those things are,
there are more and more,
um,
available here.
Um,
no,
uh,
it turns out that we actually can self induced stress without any substance,
without anything.
And um,
so that's some good news.
It seems that it's a capability that every human being house and cool.
Hannah has uncovered a way for human beings to learn how to self induce when
it's safe for that person.
And then the next is what for,
and that's where the research comes in and you're going to hear about all the
things that go is beginning to do to see cancer research,
um,
research on obesity and all sorts of healing things,
self development,
self understanding,
um,
psychiatric issues.
It can,
it can be a tool for many,
many things.
It's just the beginning of that research.
So this is a story where he had to tell you,
uh,
how it unfolded.
The reason I'm here is that,
um,
I do have a background in psychology,
but also I've worked with many shamans from around the world and I've always
thought that on that journey to become ourselves,
we need many,
many different tools.
And it was,
it's always amazing to combine psychology and this ability to go to other
dimensions.
And I met Cohi in a few years ago,
uh,
and we,
we've been working together and we're developing a protocol to integrate
self-induced trends and psychology.
And we're in the process of doing things.
We're already working with people.
It's phenomenal,
the results.
So we'll share a little bit about that.
So that's the reason that I'm here.
But,
so let's hear more about you.
And so my first question is like,
how does it happen that a Parisian very Cartesian was never dealt with?
Any of that ends up developing self induced trance?
Um,
all begin in 2001,
uh,
I was living in London at the time and dealing with the loss of my father and
dealing with the grief and the,
when my producer,
I was working in the BB World Service,
maybe she won't salvage the radio and what my project,
when,
what,
when my producer told me,
I can send you in Mongolia to do a report,
uh,
for the radio about Mongolian shamanism.
I told her,
oh,
yes.
You know,
because,
um,
the forest,
I could be the bitter.
It could be for me,
you know?
So,
um,
I went in a,
in Mongolia,
uh,
to study by what shamanism could be.
And,
um,
I met,
uh,
this shaman,
a friend of mine era,
uh,
accompanied me to,
to this place it in the north of Mongolia,
at the,
in Cheveria,
the border north Siberia.
And,
um,
as soon as the
Shaman began to,
to beat a drum,
uh,
it did something there.
We wield,
I,
I began to shake and more and more.
And I,
I was feeling like I was transforming myself in a wharf.
You know,
I began to hold like a wolf and I feel like I had a,
uh,
poles and the muzzle instead of my nose.
And it was quite weird because,
uh,
I realize what happened to me,
but I couldn't control anymore.
Plus this was very scary,
you know?
And when the drumming stop,
uh,
there's a man was speaking with my friend and,
he told her why,
why did you,
why didn't you tell me that she was a chairman?
Because according to him,
uh,
I react like that because I was a shy man.
So,
um,
it'll be both.
So now you don't have any choice.
Uh,
we are going to keep you with us for three years,
you know?
And so by id I told him no,
it's not possible.
I don't want to stay at the Syrian border for three years with you and the it
was not possible.
And,
uh,
it'll be yes,
yes,
yes.
It will be possible babies.
She,
I don't want to do that.
He told me,
you don't have any choice.
If you don't stay with us and do what the spirits are supposed to teach you,
uh,
you are going to die
by law.
So this is me.
One year later,
we used to go,
uh,
with my drum and,
he's,
um,
husbands,
uh,
Sherman,
DG with keeping me,
holding me your during the trends and um,
hi.
Hi.
Spend a lot of time in Mongolia,
you know,
uh,
it lasts eight years.
Finally,
I went few months a year in Mongolia for free,
uh,
eight years.
And,
uh,
finally,
I discover how interesting could be trance states.
What is it
that those are the main points is that during the trends you are timeless.
You know,
you don't feel it was time and you feel less so pain,
the strength increasing.
Did you see the,
the size of the drum,
you know,
the big one,
it's seven kilos,
seven to eight kilos.
So it's very,
very heavy.
And I could manage to use it four hours drumming and beating the drum for hours
without any,
uh,
any pain.
So census how shoppers and um,
the sense of self in modified of course you feel like you are an animal,
a wharf,
but it's not only one animal,
it can be,
uh,
it can be a,
um,
an entity can be a,
all the animals.
It can be a lot of things
and information.
This is a main point because during the trance,
a shaman is using this special state to reach a skew.
What he equals a so called world's periods just to get information's.
He is not able to,
to get in another state of consciousness.
So this is a really important about the trans
thought.
My question was why,
why this can put me in such a state and an interesting state.
So I decided to,
to,
to go through scientist and my,
my dream was to record my brain,
you know who EEG but the,
the scientists,
it's him
is [inaudible] is,
I'm working in a,
in Alberta,
in the hospital as a psychotherapist.
And it taught me if you want to be recorded with a knee EEG,
you are gone.
Um,
do the trance without the drum,
you know,
because uh,
when you are drumming and when the electrodes are connected to the,
to the computer,
you are going to break everything in the,
in the laboratory,
you know,
so I don't know what you are going to do and how you are going to do this.
But if you want to do the experience you will have to uh,
self induce and use.
Exactly.
So I didn't know how to,
how to self and use because in,
in Mongolia,
every Shana and use a a drum.
So I were thinking about,
um,
the,
the music of the drum.
Trying to remember the music of the drum.
It was not working.
And um,
I remember,
but at the beginning of the Trans,
I was always shaking like that,
you know.
So,
uh,
I began to,
to check and,
and um,
I could go back to the trans by this way.
So it was my safe self injection.
I didn't know yet,
but it was myself and election and everybody and his own self injection.
But at the time I realized that this was working.
I could shake and I cook food,
the trend.
So when I um,
I've been ready,
the Jeff Lawler it on me.
Okay,
now you already,
so we can uh,
do the regionals.
So,
but decided to record me.
I'm in the normal state and in a translate states.
And uh,
first I'd like to show you a little video about what is a self induced trance.
Well this is this what you are going to see is in another laboratory,
but it's more or less what I did in,
in uh,
the Alberta Hospital and I was moving much less in the Alberta hospital than,
than here.
So you are going to see how uh,
it's easy to sell FanDuel's a trans,
but what the trends can teach us.
You are a I am,
I am doing some sounds I am completely unable,
unable to do in a normal state.
I am doing some chanting and you are a,
you will be amazed by what we are able to do in this stage.
Yeah.
You all going to early Sono language.
Nobody can understand this language.
It's not identify it as a
language,
but uh,
we think it's a pre language,
no kind of pure information because when I do this language with coming out
Alona I don't think about what I am going to say,
but when I do this language,
I,
I understand the sense,
the meaning of the language,
but uh,
nobody can understand.
Okay.
Thank you.
So it's done very quick training.
Tomorrow you'll train and Domo,
it's easy to go for the twins.
It was supposed to feel
a little bit of water in front of me and the results.
I wanted to know if I could get some information from this water and to know you
a little bit of the belt.
Okay.
This is a language I was speaking about that.
So there were different types of water,
river,
an ocean and poisoned and not poisoned.
And they wanted to see if in the state of trance she could get the information
of which water,
which,
and of course she was able,
this is a sample of what you can,
you can do in a transplant.
Each trance is difference.
Uh,
as we can discover after,
um,
each one developed a kind of trance and it's not abusive like that,
but each person who is doing self and using trip,
Trans cell phone use trends is able to reveal some own capabilities.
And uh,
so it's different for each.
So after what I had to buy to do the EEG recording and um,
uh,
here is one of the first,
um,
you majors,
I don't,
on the left it's a me on a trends and on,
on the right to nine on the,
on the right,
uh,
the control group,
women,
uh,
80 people a more or less,
yes,
80 women and uh,
they wanted to compare,
uh,
the brain activity for the control group and,
and uh,
does this me and you know,
the image of a remark that the brain activity was a increase in the,
in the place where the Arrow is.
And this is me on the trends on the left and me,
uh,
on the,
on the normal state.
And there is a difference too with the brain activity different and the
increase in this special place.
So,
um,
to,
to sum up,
this is where it is increased and where it is decreased.
So it depends on the bandwidth.
Okay.
And he also,
the results before trends,
the EEG is normal,
completely normal during the trends.
There is a big modification of the brain activity.
So,
uh,
means that,
it's not magic.
You know,
the ethnologist
had the idea that it was cultural.
The trans was a cultural thing,
but a law,
we,
we did show that it,
it was a cognitive phenomenon.
Oh,
varies a right hemisphere ferric predominance.
And after the trends,
the EEG was back to normal.
So this was the first time ever that a brain under Shimony trends was studied by
scientists.
And just a few months ago they published the results in a scientific journal.
So it's the first time ever that people thought about it,
but it was the first time it was proved,
it took 10 years for this article to be published,
10 years.
So now you can consult it.
And this is a conclusion.
So it can be a powerful tool.
So Colin,
my question is once,
so you did all that research and you understood you're not crazy,
there's something happening in your brain,
why did you decide to then develop a tool to share it with others?
Um,
because thanks to,
to this,
these researchers,
I,
uh,
we,
we show that it was a cognitive phenomena.
So,
uh,
I think it was for everybody and if I was able to self and user trends,
it was possible for everybody.
So the,
the drum is a efficient to put somebody in a trends for one out of 100,000
people.
So it's zero.zero zero zero 1%.
There was only 30 Sherman in Mongolia for a population of free million.
No.
So it's very few.
So I was thinking maybe it's a drum is not efficient enough.
He's not powerful enough to put everybody in a trance.
So I was thinking about a tool we could do with IMTS,
um,
to improve this effect.
So high I had as a musician and a composer,
I um,
uh,
I found the in in the drumming some parts very,
very,
very powerful on Migraine.
I couldn't stop to go through trends when I was listening to this special little
loops from the drunk.
And I get this loops to the,
to the side to some scientist I am working with.
And the tried to find how and the why is this special sequences?
Well,
so powerful and the tray to empower them much more.
And,
uh,
we,
we create a new tool.
I had the chance to test this new tool.
It's own loop.
We call it a sound loop in liberals,
you know,
in the art school,
in the national art school in France where I am doing workshop to,
to,
to show them.
But the moment of creativity is kind of a trance to one,
you know.
So,
uh,
the,
the agreed to test the sound loop and the result was this
16 out of 20 and I took a trends.
So we realized that,
okay
everybody,
or more or less goof word trends,
but the next step was to,
to try and to teach them how to self and use it.
Wow.
Well he tested it with many,
many more groups so that you understand that of many different cultures and
different places.
We tested it also in California and a number of groups and the percentage was
always very consistent.
It was about 80% of the people,
very often people who have never experienced trends when they are exposed to the
sound loop,
boom,
they experienced something.
And we,
we the the artist we,
I will thinking it's easy with artist,
you know the know the state of course their noses thing.
But with researchers it will be different.
So we did test with all the researcher we are working with and it was the same,
the same result at the first,
at the first listening,
they could go through trends,
80% of them could,
could be able to go through trends and that take on a fellow listening.
Everybody was able to go food trends.
So it was,
and in general what happens is like if during that experience he's a person has
an experience and their body starts shaking or something like this,
whatever happens to them first might be their key to self induce.
In the same way that Colin said that to self induce,
she went back to the gesture she was making at the beginning.
So in the same way,
that's what can happen.
So this is what we're doing now when we're working with people on where,
when it's safe for them,
we're teaching them to self,
you do it,
this is what we're doing.
We're just observing what happens on their face or in their body.
And then we get them to repeat that and then boom,
they can go.
Um,
the thing is when someone goes in that state,
the person,
he's always conscious.
So it is always that observer seeing what's going on and the person can come
back whenever they want,
which is very different from taking something because when you take something,
you are under the influence,
right of the thing because then there is the physical consequences in your brain
and your body of whatever you're taking.
So this is a big difference.
Then a very interesting and important part of it was for instance,
you started,
uh,
I can talk about Francis.
Um,
and because this is the beginning of a lot of research,
someone in Paris,
one of the top researchers in France,
one of the people managing the cnrs,
which his leg,
the top,
there's no such thing in the US,
but it's like Nih plus Mit plus all the top research labs in the country.
Um,
he was diagnosed with a very bad cancer,
prostate cancer metastasize to the spine and he was given just a few months to
live and he was already paralyzed.
He was barely walking with a stick,
couldn't move the hips,
nothing really.
Um,
and because science couldn't do anything for him,
uh,
he,
he ended up with Colin and Colin said,
look,
we can try.
We can try to sell him.
Nope.
And I can try to sell you to self Angelo to plants to show you how to Seth
Andrews.
He told me,
okay.
Okay.
The next video with the first listening of the some loop.
So you're going to see is ego to food trends.
He ended,
took a trend and
you are going to see the hips moving like,
like hell,
you know,
and just watch the hips paralyzed and just watch what happens to them in the
state of trance for someone who has never experienced trans before.
Very rational scientist,
researcher.
Hmm.
So no,
Noah osteopathic,
no physiotherapist he was working with could understand any of it.
And then after that,
what happened was that he started self inducing every day.
Even in the middle of the night,
he's buddy would wake him up and just start a trance and he,
he's research is about studying,
uh,
like developing an MRI to study metabolism,
the metabolism.
And he realized basically that his body was waking up and starting the trends at
the same time,
the cancer cells were,
uh,
in their own biorhythm spreading.
So at the same time,
he's buddy automatically was waking up doing the trends and now we're 14 months
later,
he's in total remission.
He's completely healed and what they'd still need.
It's not only thanks to Lisa,
you do a lot of nutrition saint she's diets and things like that.
But this portrayal helped him to recover the body,
the body,
the by saying he's walking now,
no more stick and so on and so forth.
And so very intrigued by what it did to his body.
He is he,
for us or for other reasons,
he's created a foundation to research again,
all that stuff with the metabolism.
But one of the part of that research will be to see how can self-induced trans
help in cases of cancer.
So that leads us to the next step to the next part of our talk,
which is how can it be used,
this tool.
So one is this,
do you want to see a few more words about the foundation or Francis?
Uh,
no,
he's gonna,
he's to work on advanced missiles to,
to cure people on this.
One of this will be one of them and he's working on metabolism.
So we will be able to see how the trends can act,
have an effect or not on,
on the cell metabolism.
So this part of the working he like to do and he remarked that there is a
synaptic trace,
um,
left on the synapse,
uh,
after the trans,
you know,
and he could manage to,
to reconnect conscientiously,
uh,
to this,
Synopsis Trace.
After the trends,
though there is a really a,
a parental,
very real mark in the,
in the brain,
which could stay and,
uh,
had to,
um,
way of learning,
uh,
some,
some new,
uh,
what the body can,
can do.
And what the body has to teach you and what would you do like you to do?
Yes.
The second field of research for you,
now that you're starting in psychiatry.
So you've began to work with,
um,
a psychiatry clinic in France,
uh,
20 psychiatry's.
They're experienced a sell on loop.
And you can imagine that it's difficult for them to just let go and go into
trends and make weird noises because it might sound and look like they are our
patients,
you know?
So there might be some resistance in that group,
but actually,
again,
almost all of them experienced trends,
which is amazing.
And of course it was the first time for them.
And so you're developing a program now,
a pilot program with them to see how it can be used in case of dissociative
patients.
Okay.
In this case,
so a dissociative disorder,
depression,
panic attacks,
and PTSD.
So this is just the beginning.
We didn't
do anything yet,
but we got the authorization to start this pilot program.
The name of psychiatry.
See Dr. Allen One and uh,
is very,
uh,
very eager to begin this kind of,
researchers.
Yeah.
One of the examples,
just to give you an example is the idea is that when a client has a patient,
has a dissociative episode,
you know,
schizophrenia person and they just go and it's usually extremely painful,
extremely traumatizing,
difficult to come back and so on and so forth.
With the trends it might,
it might help them go in a controlled way in that state and learn to come back
much more gently.
And if they learned the the path back and forth,
but in a gentle and Safeway,
maybe it can diminish the trauma and the pain when they just have an episode.
Maybe,
maybe it can do something about the frequency of the episodes.
We don't know you're going to see.
So that's one thing.
And the PTSD,
uh,
that's a really important thing because of course you might have heard there's a
lot of research using LSD or Psilocybin for PTSD and depression and all sorts of
things like that.
But there might be side effects to those things.
So now it would be interesting again to use self induced trance.
He said,
No side effect for those things.
And you're developing a program with again,
the CNRS and the brain machine interface.
Um,
what,
what is important,
it's no big to,
to,
to be able to self and a trench.
You need the key before to go through the state and to know what is a state,
you know,
to the key can be the song loop then,
but French laboratory,
uh,
ask,
if it could be possible to help them to develop a brain machine interface to
help people to go for the Trans.
And after that we'll elbow elbow to safe and end users the trends.
So this is a new,
a new project we have with the French,
uh,
laboratory to,
to set up this kind of brain machine computer on this with this,
with a new adventure.
Yeah.
Cultural reality.
Because of course that might lend itself very well,
you know,
to taking people on a journey where they can then self juice.
The next field,
uh,
educational field.
You,
you,
you saw,
uh,
during the chance I am able to do something in clinical,
no,
I am not able to do in my normal state.
So some other researcher in another laboratory.
I think that,
uh,
it could be interesting to test two to test what we,
we could be able to learn during as a state trends because we realize that some
inhibited system,
um,
uh,
removed during our moved,
during the,
during the trance state.
So it's
should be why you are so able to do something we don't know.
We are able to do no.
So,
but like to,
to use this specialty to,
to,
to test and to try to know where and how we could learn and what we could learn
in this special thing.
We all know we have so many later and capabilities,
right?
And for instance,
in a,
in circumstance of high danger,
we certainly can run faster than we ever thought we could.
So we have those capabilities in us.
And so,
so many.
So the idea is like,
okay,
let's try in itself into state and see what we can explore.
And,
um,
the last 20 psychology,
and this is where we collaborating.
And,
um,
now it's been a year.
So there's more,
um,
I mean we,
we,
we've worked with a number of people,
so now we can see a bit how it works.
So,
um,
it's fascinating to see what happens when you,
when you combine verbal and nonverbal.
Basically when you combine the more classical tools of psychology,
even dreamwork which already goes into the unconscious somewhere and Colin's
work and the capability to self induced.
So just to give you an example,
um,
with a few people I work with and we go deep in that kind of one on one work,
there were things we could not understand where it was coming from.
You know,
like some deep anxiety or some deep phobias and the person we just couldn't and
nothing was appearing in the dreams because that person was too stressed to even
remember their dreams or you know,
whatever was happening.
And so we couldn't trace the,
you know,
the core,
the root cause of that problem.
And if we can't understand the root cause,
we can't change it.
And then that person who had never experienced or ever,
ever,
ever experienced strengths was exposed to the cell and loop.
Boom.
It was phenomenal what she experienced.
And then we spent more time with her and we were able,
so she was able to self induce.
And then when she was before stuff in juicing,
we ask the question because that's the thing,
when you're going to trends,
you can either just go and see what shows up in terms of material,
which you see what you feel,
which were body does or actually you can ask a question,
you can have an intention.
And so we did that a number of times where we asked a question about key points
we could never understand and she got answers that I don't know how long it
would have taken in the more classical therapy,
um,
to get those answers.
And it comes in a way which is so real that it gets etched in the sales.
You know,
it gets etched in your understanding in a different way.
It's not intellectual because you really feel it.
And so it was a big breakthrough.
And then I come even when we do the integration,
the verbal integration,
because again,
and Coleen keeps insisting on that to have a trans experience of just for the
sake of it,
she calls it,
told them an edge,
which I love in French.
You know,
like when you do a car who sell a thing,
it's like just entertainment.
It's just an Aha moment,
you know?
And then what if you don't work on the material that's being revealed if you
don't work on how to integrate it in your life,
what's the point?
I mean,
and worst case actually,
what gets exposed is actually traumatizing or painful material.
And if there's nobody to help you integrate that,
it's actually dangerous.
So we,
that
the spirits are saying yes,
right?
So,
so this is what we're developing.
We're developing a protocol,
um,
to also teach people to self-induced when it's safe and so on and so forth.
Individuals.
And I'm so as you can hear about all those things,
um,
this is an ancestral timeless capability
in every human being.
But now with science and technology we can explore in differently and where it's
like really beginning to discover a new continent.
Every single we're describing in how to use the tool for all those different
things.
It's just the beginning of the research.
So we don't have any answer yet,
but this is the beginning and the readership are eager to go through that and
the thing,
but it is promising.
But so that's it for fall now and uh,
we have to say to the tweet,
it's not possible to lead this kind of tool for everybody in all ways.
It will be just for people train with it and positions and psychiatry and people
were able to,
to manage this without any danger.
So that's it.
Very exciting things.
We have a few minutes for questions.
So
yes
speaking,
no they don't.
There are people drinking anymore.
Okay.
So the first question is,
you mentioned the brain machine interface.
So what's the idea behind that?
Like the whole,
like you would have some sort of a machine that affects like a brain waves and
stuff and then put you into a trust.
The computer will analyze you.
You,
you have a electrodes on your head on in the brain machine system and the
computer will analyze the brain waves and help you to go through trends through
a special,
uh,
there would just read your brain waves and,
and help you to go through a trans.
Because I am,
I'm gonna give my head,
you know,
to do some marks and to educate what is trance state to the computer.
And on this a researcher will be able to,
to create,
um,
Como [inaudible].
Yeah.
So basically by recording her,
putting that in the program,
the computer program will know what,
where the brain of that person should go to access that trends.
And so,
so that's what,
that's what the
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah,
Exactly.
Are you going though?
Neurofeedback?
Okay.
And then the second question is,
was the difference between this chance and then self hypnosis?
I know we,
we did some research in the MRI just to know what parts of the brain were
activated during the,
just when I decide to go through trends or when somebody decided to go to an
independent hypnosis experience.
And the MRI showed that it was different,
a place in the brain which will activated during a trans,
this kind of trends and the hypnosis trance.
Okay.
So you're saying it's a different thing,
what seems to be,
seems to me,
however
different you both of the brain activation.
Okay.
And I have another,
maybe a wild one,
but I learned a lot would be the difference between this and the state of,
and a lie to the person.
Like,
you know,
some guru that achieve like,
hello.
Uh,
we did some,
some,
uh,
EEG experience too.
And um,
uh,
they realized that between the Trans,
commodity to hot,
yeah.
When the person is resting in my to address
great wrestling state between the trenches,
well,
similar to the meditation experience and people will meditating a lot and it's
kind of
same.
There's the same till I had,
I hired and I had,
so I had,
I had experience with some AI in enlightment during,
during some trenches.
Not each time,
but uh,
I had,
so that was really fascinating that in the resting state,
her brain is the same as the one of extremely advanced meditators who have
meditated for decades.
We,
because they compared her to Buddhist monks basically.
Thank you.
Yes.
So they're in the trance state.
There's a resting period between the transitions,
is that what you're saying?
Equals a special,
a experiment experimentation.
So they asked me to go through trends to stop and another one and stop and
another one they thought they could,
they could eat my brain too,
to know what,
but actually I just wanted to add that my own experience,
self reported experience of a lot of people who've I learned with her.
Um,
it's a,
it's a sort of high,
you know,
like it's a sort of place of empowerment and high after the trends that might be
that thing of in life man,
close to it.
So yeah.
And can you tell us which part of the brain the this trans activates it.
It's written into the article you are going to see.
Yes.
It's not my field.
I'm committed.
One of the last things that you mentioned that you said that you don't have the
answers yet and I was just wondering what some of the most pressing questions.
Where would you that you have in other words you you want,
the last thing is you mentioned accordion [inaudible] speak slowly because it's
short.
You want it to last things you said was that you don't have,
he said,
oh we don't have the answers yet and I was only wondering what like what are
some of the most pressing questions that you're looking for?
It's a quick history.
The,
the answer we are looking for and does it works in,
in Ptsd that it worked with the dissociation tribal,
does it work?
This is the answer we'd like to have,
but we,
we,
we tried on a few people's,
so it's promising,
but it's not a,
you know,
you can,
you can count on this and
five people is not all,
you know,
so we have to go further.
That's the second thing of book.
The two of us here,
we're both documentary filmmakers and we're working on a project where there's
a,
there's a doctor in the MD phd that worked on something in the fifties and
sixties is fairly similar to this work at least in touching some of it.
And uh,
but no one really listened to him.
And I was wondering like,
how do you have similar issues?
And in other words,
are there trends in some sense?
Um,
uh,
do you have any issues with getting,
getting the,
some of your research seen,
uh,
by it either way,
the academic community or other communities that you're just kind of getting the
attention of people because just because it's on,
it's not necessarily a,
yes,
there's,
we seem to be opening a psilocybin and Lsd,
some of these things as being options for treating PTSD.
And other things.
And so I just,
I,
my question is,
um,
do you have any issues with,
with uh,
beginning your work,
seen,
seen and understood easily?
I guess by the academic community
it is controversial for people who just don't know,
so they hear that they associated to his weird things,
you know,
just out of ignorance.
Um,
and so for Coleen I can say it,
she couldn't say it.
It's been an amazingly courageous journey.
Uh,
and also she's in France,
you know,
it's not California,
it's a little bit less or it used to be a little bit less open to all those
things.
Um,
so,
so yes,
it's been difficult,
but that's cool.
It says if it hasn't been that difficult it would,
maybe she would not have been that rigorous in her scientific grounding of that
work.
You know,
because she's so much wants to make sure that nobody can find the breach into
that work and nobody can say,
you know,
it's Voodoo is Shama and blah,
blah,
blah.
With their associations,
with those words that it forced her to do it in a super rigorous way.
Yes,
yes.
But it is challenging,
but it is,
there is a momentum right now because Justin,
the last few months,
oldest things have been happening.
So it's like her work of 17 years,
he's no beginning to,
to pay a lot of fruits,
which is beautiful for the benefit of all sentient beings.
Um,
I had,
uh,
I was really interested in,
um,
when you would be in this state,
you said you had said there was of a certain language that would come out and
you were unsure of where this was coming from.
Is there any,
oh,
are you doing anything to look into that?
And is there any sort of research?
Not yet.
It'll,
it was not a priority,
but we should,
we have a lot to do and to try to understand what is the language,
what could be associated to this,
uh,
kind of language.
Yes.
Could you,
would you compare that to something,
you know,
like automatic writing and,
and,
you know,
that sort of thing.
It's comes along like automatic writing comes,
you know,
comes through somewhere.
We don't know.
We don't know,
but this comes out.
But,
uh,
it has a meaning.
Uh,
you understand the meaning when you say you to tell it,
but we don't know where it comes from.
I just want to add one thing to you that um,
in the sessions we do one on one with people calling does a trails on them
first.
And in several cases when Colin is doing her trust,
the person begin answering in that same language and they were like having a
dialogue somewhere.
I'm really understanding each other.
That's very interesting.
Yeah.
Can you twice I was talking about the prayer language.
It's something we couldn't tell you directly to your,
to your cells instead of fuel mine.
You know,
it's just very,
well we then very interesting I think and people whose native tongue that are
different.
So again,
really intriguing.
Yup.
Uh,
just a quick followup question,
uh,
are you aware of that this is all visit observation.
So you were recording yourself or you're observing someone.
Are you aware of things that you are saying and doing with the,
with the body in that trance state?
Is the person aware of the things that they are saying?
No,
wait,
yes.
That's the new thing.
That's the thing.
There's always an observer aware of what's going on always.
And you can always decide to come back.
The Observer is there.
Quick question,
another quick question.
So seizures are also,
uh,
electrical activity in the brain.
This is also,
it seems,
seems like an electrical activity in the brain.
How do they compare?
One is in monetary,
the other one is voluntary,
please.
Not The difference.
Seizures
[inaudible]
commodity component.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh no,
the,
the EEG showed that it was completely different.
Interesting.
That's
completely different,
but very keen.
Mongolia in Mongolia,
some epileptics,
a soft kind of epilepsy,
but we don't know which one are compelled to Shamanic,
uh,
to show many powers
in many traditions.
Extra the right.
Yeah.
People are considered the showmans.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So it's not all the epilepsy,
but some of them are.
Consider Shannon.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hi.
Thank you for the talk.
I just have a question about diet.
This is,
it is a stunning special diet that will help to induce trance states.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Do the youth was for Francis,
the researcher,
uh,
to,
to help the,
to heal the cancer.
It was just for,
for him.
But we don't have any diet in this kind of,
uh,
practice.
We should maybe.
Yeah.
I was wondering in Mongolia with the Shamans,
do they have certain age limits before it will they let children partake in
Trans states?
And then how does that translate into you?
It's not a low the children,
no.
Wait,
um,
uh,
the children is,
well 18,
19,
20,
it's not,
never another before that age and a,
the end of the practice.
It depends on your teeth.
Really.
Yes.
If she lose your teeth,
you lose your power.
Why?
Because you are not able to eat meat.
So you need to eat meat.
Yeah.
You let culture talking about diet.
Yes.
But usually in,
in a family when a child shows signs of something,
it often starts with a child being very sick and uh,
on usually like they don't understand what's going on and then they take the
child to a shaman and the Shama and might say,
Ooh,
this one has the skills.
You know,
usually from an then sister and they explained to the family if you don't train
the child,
the child my died might have more and more illnesses,
more and more problems.
But then the age apprenticeship,
I think a,
it's on average 13 years in Mongolia,
the apprenticeship to become a shaman.
So it's not like,
okay I'm going a few months in the Amazon and then under showman it's 13 years
of very harsh a presence apprenticeship too to be able to deal with all those
dimensions.
And have you heard of light language because it sounds like what you were,
what I observed is similar to what people called light language.
I don't know.
I can connect you with some yeah,
yeah.
Yes,
yes.
Do you see your work as having similarities to,
I'll look tropic breath work and if so,
do you like want to work with them,
um,
to get
uptake in the psychiatric community if,
if your research is successful?
Yes.
Holotropic breath work.
Cause there's a,
there are a lot of parallels between what this tool can do and uh,
many other things,
you know,
like that.
Um,
what we've seen with a lot of people who've experienced holotropic breathwork is
like the intensity,
the physicality,
you know,
like all that happens.
Like that this doesn't happen in this,
it's like much lighter,
you know,
I was an experience but um,
definitely,
definitely because it's like those are just,
those are different tools to access there.
So absolutely.
And Stung growth is aware of our work,
but each store,
this is interesting because each tool send you in,
in different places.
So this kind of a tool could help you to do some research in a certain field,
but this kind of can,
can go,
went to a training.
So each tool as his own interests.
Yeah.
Can we experience the sound loop?
Well,
it may not today,
but uh,
we definitely use it in our,
in our one on one work.
Um,
so definitely that's a setting.
Good.
Organize a workshop in,
in Google we could organize a workshop,
Eh,
you,
you have to be,
uh,
10,
10 is a good amount of people.
Uh,
we need good speakers and a,
and it's possible.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
usually in the workshop with the artist,
it takes three days to teach them how to self induce a trans,
no free free days of practicing the trends.
It means a seven,
eight trends and after the able to cell phone use and also the,
it,
no,
it's not that long.
So it depends off each of course.
Uh,
some will need more time to Seth Andrews or trans,
but z average is around this.
Well,
thank you very much.
Uh,
it was beautiful to share all of this with you.
Um,
again,
this beautiful idea of the encounter between an ancient technology and the new
technology,
especially being here at Google,
I think is quite intriguing.
I hope it piqued your curiosity and a much,
much,
much more to explore.
Thank you,
Maria.
It's again.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.